after training for days on Twitter the
social co-host Jessica Allen is
apologizing for her comments that were
in response to Don Cherry being fired
from what does you people rant
here's what Jessica said on Tuesday's
episode I don't worship at the altar of
hockey I never have and maybe it's
because of where I grew up but there's a
and going to a couple different
universities there's a certain type of
person in my mind in my experience who
does and they all tended to be white
boys who weren't let's say very nice
they were not generally thoughtful they
were often bullies their parents were
able to afford to put them you know
spend five thousand dollars a year on
minor hockey instead of buses and owes a
lot of money you can do other things
besides spending your time in an arena
you can go on a trip and learn about the
world see other things a you know like
it's the place maybe gets out of that
bubble and for me Don Cherry is the
walking and talking representative of
that type he's the type of person but
now people wanted like and I know he's
done some good things but at the same
time when someone good is also too able
to make fun of people who believe in
climate science who's also able to be
like whether he's charming or not but
he's still a bigot and a misogynist when
you're what you know to have those two
things like
I'm embarrassing I find it embarrassing
that there's a big chunk of the country
that is so upset about this hockey
doesn't mean anything to me I'm sorry
it's in your celebration okay so just to
quickly trended after that she's been
trending for four days now with the
hashtag fire Jess Allen boycott the
social boycott CTV which is the network
that the show airs on have all been
trending so Jessica issued this apology
last night I do have regrets I regret
saying that my experiences were personal
instead of underlining that they were
specific episodes from determined
moments with particular individuals as a
result I offended many people not just
our viewers but parents children coaches
volunteers and hockey families
everywhere to you I apologize but I
still can't apologize to them very
specific hockey players I was referring
to on Tuesday I wish I'd use my voice
and my privilege more back then yes I
mean obviously we talked about Don
Cherry a few days ago but obviously we
we do the same show here where we're
giving our opinions on stuff yeah I said
the same thing about Don Cherry like
when you know a couple days after we're
saying oh no I meant to say this instead
but he didn't want to apologize on air
about it like that's where Don Cherry
kind of lost me so this is just kind of
apologizing well she has apologized for
it yeah and yeah because her rant I
found it when I saw it I found it very
strange and kind of like whoa what's
going on here's obviously there's
something very very personal that she
has personal history with people that
played hockey certain people that played
hockey but no I did find her statement
made this very blanket statement about
all people that involved in a hockey
world which was very kind of jarring so
I do think she definitely needed
pologize I know she ignored it a little
bit for a couple days hoping it would go
away but it hasn't gone away on social
media so she has apologized so I think
it's kind of up to people now mm-hmm
is that enough you think it's nothing
yeah you know it's I was starting with
the Don chair and you guys already
talked about it on Facebook live I I sat
back for a bit before making the I was
asked about my opinion on social media
what I thought of the whole thing and I
finally did post about it and I got
bombarded with messages slew of messages
about what was happening and it wasn't
even just the you people it's the honey
and no
gonna just totally wrapped around what
he was trying to say yeah yeah and I
think was a the right thing to do to let
him go I don't know I don't know if that
was the right move this show is about
talking about your experiences and when
she's talking you could see the passion
in her work you could see that she's
kind of blurting words out as she's
trying to explain her experience I'm
still having pain there is there's
something going on and sometimes when
you're that passion and you're talking
about something it's not exactly the way
you want it to come up politically
correct I'm putting it in quotes I'm so
happy that she apologized of course it's
jessica is one of the one of the
sweetest people in the world and I think
people who know who knows that but when
you're on a platform from like that on a
show like that where you are having
conversations you do have to be careful
what you say because people and and
right now it's just so hard you don't
know what is the right thing to say as
well but she has been been attacked a
lot on social media I'm glad that she
put a statement out there on Twitter and
I hopefully this doesn't lead to her
getting fired we got to think about
everything else we know she's not a
racist we know her comments were from a
place of her own experiences but the way
it came out I understand how people were
but I think like that's the whole
problem when you make these blanket
statements about a certain group of
people that's really really running into
problems see I understand this it's kind
of mentioned the fact that it's her
experience like she says that I don't
think she's out there to generalize but
that's how we came across that statement
if you listen to it again I watched it a
few times she is talking about her
experience but then she talks about how
she doesn't like hockey she doesn't like
the culture of hockey
that's her experience but you're right
it's it's it
generalized a little bit too much but I
don't think she should get fired for
this no I know it says it's a good
apology she was very articulate unless
it says I think she did a good apology
Jose says her statement of what this
hockey thing is strange when you get too
excited by something sometimes we say
stop really fast and not thinking yeah
Nelson says people shouldn't apologize
that this blows things up but no this is
something that's been going on for four
days that gets more train
on Twitter for four days I have a
question for you and this is something
that I think about since the soul of Don
Cherry thing happen are you careful with
what you say now are you are you sitting
back on your opinions now that show like
this where we're live and we're talking
about our opinions do you feel now that
you have to be careful with we do this
for three years now obviously we do the
whole gamut of topics so yeah no I'm not
conscious of holding back my opinions
but I'm conscious of how I say those
opinions for sure yeah yeah but I never
felt like oh I'm not gonna say that
because that'll get me in trouble but
yeah we're always honest but yeah yeah
obviously yeah you're saying it too if
you got in sudden be careful of how you
say it so and it but I think that's part
of what this job is right let me you're
saying it you guys need to be careful
what you're yeah but for me it's X it's
where's that border of like you need to
have a conversation to continue moving
that conversation there are certain
things you have to take to the edge to
get this conversation going and that's
what that's my fear with everything
that's happening right now on television
is that gonna now just make everyone
just kind of stop right and just staple
it up I think you should consciously
don't make blatant statements about yeah
I mean don't ya but I I understand what
she was saying and I think if you know
her or even if you know the show that
was in her messaging and that's the
center